hey what's going on ladies and gentlemen
welcome back to part three of the plot
leak discussion I had with the dawn of
Ice and Fire I hope you guys have been
enjoying these videos by having dawn on
the channel this should give you guys a
different perspective on these leaks and
help you see things from a different
angle I appreciate those of you that
have taken the time to watch these and
those of you that have went and
subscribed to a Donna bison fires
channel he released a new video today
that you should definitely go and check
out after you finish listening to this
one I will provide the link to his
channel and to his news video down in
the description now let's get things
started
okay John and Davos arrival on
Dragonstone and meet Tyrion on the beach
tyrion brings them to meet Daenerys Dany
demands John to bend the knee which he
refuses John instead tells her about the
white Walker threat but she doesn't
believe him
Davos tries to tell her about Jon's
resurrection but John dismisses it
Tyrion steps in to say John's a good guy
and definitely not insane
Dany respects John immediately although
John doesn't return the sentiment Jon
meets Theon who presumably meets with as
a typo it says Jon meets Theon who
presumably meets with Theon and promises
to spare his life for what he did
helping sons of escape arya encounters
her old direwolf Nymeria on the way to
Winterfell Jorah and Sam meet an old
town and find a cure for greyscale then
bran arrives at Winterfell and Mira
returns home to the neck okay so hmm
let's start off from the beginning so
John and doggles
arrive at Dragonstone Denny rolls up on
him bending knee
and John hits her with the you know head
when I step on yeah he hits a missile
with that wild and talk hello yes sir
Neal I'm gonna Dorf like you think you
think he will refuse that um yeah you
know I collected I could see him saying
hey my people made me King in the north
I'm not just going to kneel to you right
now
I agree I don't see him bending his knee
ever again yeah you know so um now you
know what's the one thing that that kind
of that kind of got me a little bit the
part where it's like Davos
tries to tell Danny about Jon's
resurrection and John dismisses it
uh-huh why would John dismiss the part
about his resurrection I think maybe
that's the type of when a meant to say
that Danny dismisses it because that's
the only thing that kind of makes sense
you know only because even though Danny
herself has you know become a walking
miracle I think that because of the fact
that she lost her husband the way that
she did that she will probably be very
skeptical of a guy who supposedly died
and came back and is pretty normal
yeah I agree that's a very good point
and John not not respecting Danny um
that doesn't really seem like John's
character to not like respect somebody
yeah I mean that seems out of place
friend I mean because if I go I so
Tyrion convinces Danny that John is
telling truth and then Danny respects
John but then John doesn't respect Danny
that doesn't make sense
yeah it doesn't make sense for a few
reasons one
she's got three big-ass dragons to she
currently controls you know if you count
currently controlled Dragonstone the
reach parts of the Iron Islands and
Dorne which mean she's that almost as
much of the realm as John does having
the north
she still has marine - this is true even
though I thought they she left you know
ruling council they're supposed to pick
a new rule or something like that and
free elections
but yeah it could be it could be
something like that but I just kind of
figured with her leaving Dario behind it
was still kind of you know she wanted to
go back and rule it was still hers for
the taking
I mean I could definitely see that you
know and plus it is called the bay
dragons absolutely but yeah we can we
can move forward past I just wanted to
mention that real quick but you're
probably right that they'll probably set
up their own little government there
yeah man so something what else we have
there uh so John what he is trying to
parlay for the drag for the dragonglass
right and I think I actually missed that
from the last episode so you know it
makes sense about trying to parlay for
the dragonglass yeah he definitely knows
he left it at a hard home so he knows he
needs some desperately well the question
is then you know what is going to be the
trade-off because yeah even though
Stannis was the guy who ruled there
remember that is the ancestral seat of
Targaryen and none of these people know
anything about John's roots at this
point so if he's coming to her Island at
her behest
she's like bend the knee he like no I
just came here for the dragon glass and
I'm out like alright well look first off
I don't even believe when your damn
White Walkers and second all right
even if I did you're asking me if you
can just snatch up this dragon glass
from from here well what am I getting in
return for you getting all of this
dragon glass that she supposedly need
the fright of war yeah that's true she
may want something in return right so I
don't know I mean if John is not going
to bend a knee then the question must be
asked you know what is he willing to
offer her in order to obtain that dragon
glass yeah I think I think this is
probably where Tyrion is going to come
into play a lot and kind of help
negotiate terms on getting Dany to help
on and have John you know help her in
some way as well that is a very
interesting and very plausible what do
you think about John meeting Theon on
the beach we have seen the spoiler photo
that shows those two on the beach how do
you think that's going to go down what
do you think John's going to say to him
um I mean well we've already seen him
choking fian yes oh so I mean that's
going to be interesting just in terms of
you know we have John who's probably
gonna see beyond uh not necessarily by
chance but it won't I don't think it'll
be a set meeting you know where it's
just like okay um yeah see on John you
guys haven't seen each other in a while
you know be you want to talk talk to
fallout I think it's going to be one of
those John is walking along the beach
and and then just happens to spot see on
kind of things yeah and I think at this
point feelings going to be kind of under
the rest because you know he was just
attacked his sister was just kidnapped
he's probably rushing back to
Dragonstone kind of like in a panic
looking for Danny like hey we need some
help we were just taken out at sea right
so I don't like I said I just think it's
going to be littles kind of chance
encounters and then when he actually you
know sees them it's going to be
something what do you think about Arya
encountering her old direwolf nigh Mary
on the way to Winterfell do you think we
could see not marry again I think is
very possible that we could see Nymeria
again but then we have to think about
the question like is there a t is there
a countdown clock wrapped around my
various neck you know because we've seen
what Dan and Dave have been doing with
the direwolf and it's like come on dudes
seriously meant like can we get
freaking joy right now or you're just
going to you know slay all the
direwolves so you can save a little bit
of money for the Dragons right right
yeah
that's one thing that kind of bothered
me to me because the dire wolves are
such a like integral part of the Starks
and for them to barely be in the show
and even when some of them are still
alive they're just never with their
owner it's kind of I've never liked that
yeah and we're gonna have to see what
they do as far as a Nymeria thing
because really Nymeria was supposed to
be a big part of arias story with her
warding in the books you know that was
kind of how she figured up it but she
could warg even though she didn't fully
understand it yeah yeah they gave her
absolutely none of the working story at
all in fact in the show pretty much the
only one who can do any kind of working
news brand which I'm like okay um yeah
just you know strip all talk through the
towers yeah why do you think they did
that like I don't understand why they
think the audience isn't smart enough to
be able to distinguish the two
characters um honestly speaking I think
it may have had to do with budgeting
issues and also trying to streamline the
story so it's like we're going to give
each of the star children their own
special ability or their own particular
thing so it's like bran is brand is the
magic Stark right you know he's the one
with all three actual magical powers
Arya they made it so that she doesn't
have any magical powers on their own but
she was still able to learn some tricks
from the faceless men yep
you know John he is the guy who's always
trying to do the right thing he want to
get killed by the Nights Watch but it
was someone else's magical power that
brought him back and now everyone knows
him he's the chosen one
robbed and Rickon on the other hand
unfortunately you know they didn't
really give them anything I mean robbed
they gave him the the appearance of
being a good king but he made way too
many fuck-ups and that's how to read
what happened yeah yeah definitely man
and Rickon oh my god didn't didn't do a
damn thing with Rickon well pretty
disappointing to have a stark just like
be thrown to the wayside like that right
and then you know last but not least the
only one that has you know it didn't
have a direwolf for any real length of
time was Sansa you know um
they killed off a direwolf in season one
and she basically been nothing but a
puppet this entire time and I'm hoping
that we actually get to see a more
well-rounded since uh I mean like we got
a glimpse of it at the end of bad all
the bastards when she killed Ramsay you
know we got another glimpse when she
gets a threatened Littlefinger earlier
in the season but other than that there
was a lot to be desired with with Sansa
so hopefully they actually do something
powerful with her character yeah I think
in season 7 we're definitely going to
start seeing a lot more that change at
least I hope so just for the sake of her
character right we need Senza to be
redeemed absolutely definitely okay so
this next little part in this episode it
says Jorah and Sam meet in old town and
find a cure for greyscale now from the
spoiler photos we do know for a fact
that Jorah meets up with Dany again and
I've always assumed that that meant he
did get his greyscale sure because she
told him you know don't return to me
until you get yourself cured right so
you know the thing that I'm wondering
now is like how to Sam find that out
about
that's what I was going to say how they
going to explain this what's the cure
right I mean not only what is the cure I
mean that and that's if they decide to
tell us about what the cure is because
it could just be a thing where oh I read
stuff in an old book and then the next
thing you know you're is cured and we
don't actually get a particular remedy
for how to cure grey scale because
greyscale in the books is a lot more
detailed you know between serene having
greyscale and John Connaughton
contracting to greyscale like greyscale
is a big thing definitely in Essos so
it's been a it's a big point of
contention like well how do you wanna uh
how do you wind up trying to cure these
people a greyscale instead of living you
know having them living with the follows
yeah instead of having them live out in
the sorrows with the rest of the stone
men so it's going to be interesting just
to see how they how they're going to say
that Jorah was cured and if he's still
going to have like the flaky greyscale
on the way serene had on her face yeah
I'm kind of wondering if that's going to
be permanently there as well there's
actually been something going around
that said Sam cures it using dragon
glass which I really don't understand
yeah I mean like oh okay well here's the
thing right
dragon glass caring greyscale I don't
think it's going to be a thing of him
necessarily just plunging dragon blasts
into his arm and know why now I'm cured
of greyscale no no way
yeah probably something about breaking
up the dragon glass and you know heating
it up or boiling it in some water and
then making rinconete or no other thing
maybe making a bandage out of it and
putting it on the air
affected area yes that's possible I
thought you was actually going to say
like brew it some way oh no I was saying
like breaking it up into like a powder
and then maybe boiling it or like with
some other kind of herb or something and
then making it almost like a like a
staff or a paste yeah I was going to say
a paste or something and rub it in kind
of like some ointment right right yeah
that's possible I mean we know pretty
much anything related to the Dragons has
all these different like magical
properties so you know if they explained
it you know I could buy it true indeed
true indeed um so what do we got next is
part of this episode or was that was
that everything for the UH it just said
that brand arrives in Winterfell and
mirror returns home to the neck um yeah
I mean if anything that could probably
be one of those kind of bookend scenes
where just you know shows brand arriving
at the door and then maybe mirror like a
you know traveling the kingsroad or
something like that
do you think that could be what sahn's
is seeing in that official photo that
HBO released where it looks like she's
out in the godswood and she kind of has
a surprised or shocked look on her face
like it's very subtle
oh could be I mean I you know because at
this point I think the only people that
know will support or supposedly know
that brand was live were John and Sam
right so yeah this isn't something that
everyone else thinks the brand is dead
so you know imagine he shows up and
remember since I haven't seen him in
years
well Theon did say that he didn't kill
them so she knows that Theon didn't kill
him but that doesn't mean he survived
you know this entire time either correct
and plus you got to think about it you
know the last it means I don't know
he knows that he was supposedly went
north of the wall right so all she knows
is just that brand and written Rickon
got split up and no one seen bran ever
since yeah I don't think anybody knows
he went north of the wall he had that
chance to reunion like have a reunion
with John at Craster's keep but he ended
up leaving while John was still fighting
so I don't think anybody knows he's up
there unless OSHA said something to me
numbers possible I guess I still can't
believe they had two young boys betray
the Starks yeah and you know what sad is
small jaw number like he he was such a
great character he was only in the show
for a little time but he had that like
powerful look he would have been an
awesome character to actually be
fighting with John from here on out yeah
oh wow
can't win them all yep absolutely right
okay let's move on to episode four all
right folks that is the end of part
three on behalf of a dawn of Ice and
Fire and I we appreciate you for being
here don't forget to like this video if
you enjoyed the conversation and
subscribe to both channels if you want
to see more as always thank you for the
support and your kind words I will see
you down in the comment section bye